hey you guys flickers of fear time and
uh you know just as i mentioned on a
couple of my last videos i decided that
in the month of december i was going to
do a bunch of horror movies that were
either
christmas adjacent or kind of christmas
horror movies or at least one that was
sent set in the winter time the thing
about it is that i know there's like a
[ __ ] ton of christmas horror movies
but
we've covered a lot of them prior like
we already did black christmas we
already did kind of like the heavy
hitter ones and a lot of the other ones
are like so shitty that i'm not really
even sure that i want to waste my time
on it so i don't want to limit myself to
just christmas horror movies so i'm
going to do like ones that are just set
in the wintertime uh just like i did
with dad of dead of winter which again
not christmas but same kind of thing now
this movie here was one
again this was one that i had never
heard of prior
it came out in 2008 and it's called the
children it's a british film now don't
confuse it with uh there was actually
kind of a
another like killer kid type of movie
that came out back in 1980 that was also
called the children although i think
that has subsequently been retitled i
think it's called the children of
ravensback or something like that and
i've actually seen that and it's not
great um it's okay but you know but this
is like a completely different movie it
is killer kids so it does have a similar
setup and a similar premise
but it's much much better in quality i
have to say
so i first heard about this on one of
those lists of you know best horror
movies you've never seen blah blah
because like i said honestly
this even got a limited theatrical
release in the uk
didn't really do all that great and so
was never released in the us you know to
theaters or anything so i kind of feel
like this was one that flew under the
radar and that's really a shame because
this is an excellent killer kids movie
and it's an excellent sort of christmas
adjacent type of movie it was directed
by uh tom shankland now he's made a
handful of films uh this you know this
is one of his i think he's only made
like one or two
after this one he's actually more known
for tv like he's done a lot of british
tv he's done some episodes of ripper
street and he's done some american tv as
well he's done some uh some marvel stuff
like iron fist and the punisher and um i
think he did some episodes of house of
cards as well so that's kind of where
most of his uh most of his expertise
lies but uh as i said it's kind of sad
that he hasn't made like more movies
because this is a pretty goddamn great
killer kid movie and one that because i
kind of feel like when you do killer kid
movies one sometimes you know
particularly american filmmakers i feel
like and this is a generalization
obviously because there are exceptions
but i do kind of feel like they
maybe shy away from showing violence
toward children uh this one not so much
this one pretty much goes for it um and
also
this one doesn't really have any kind of
it doesn't really have any black humor
to it and it's not i mean it's a pretty
serious grim situation
and
as i said it doesn't really shy away
from violence either you know the kids
doing violence to the adults or the
adults having to fight back and you know
kill the kids to basically keep to save
themselves so
if that if that sounds like something's
gonna bother you because the kids are
pretty cute and they're like realistic
and everything but
this is gonna make you
as cute as the kids are and as arguably
not really their fault it is you're
still gonna be like yeah [ __ ] that kid
you know what i mean it's like a really
good birth control this movie is too and
it's and even before they start like you
know even before they start killing
people so many of them is just you know
really overwhelming and you're just kind
of like oh my god it's like i can't even
so what we have this is it's not set on
christmas i my understanding was that
this was kind of like a boxing day to
new year's type situation because i kind
of feel like maybe
there's this one family and they had
their own christmas at home and now
they're coming to you know the extended
family to celebrate boxing day new
year's they're going to stay for a week
or whatever so that's kind of what i uh
got from it so the family that's coming
there is her mom elaine and she has a
elaine's husband jonah
and elena jonah have two
younger kids like little kids miranda
and paulie i think miranda looks like
she's about maybe five or six polly
looks maybe about four or five something
like that
now elaine also has an older teenage
daughter named casey who is just kind of
over this [ __ ] um you know what i mean
the great thing about this is that the
characterization in this is really good
like all the actors
are very
naturalistic um you can really get a
sense of
these are actual family members um you
know the way they interact with one
another is just very you know i think i
said this in one other movie review or a
book review that i was doing but the
interactions between them are very
organic so i don't really know a lot
about the production of this movie but
it does kind of feel like
one of those situations where they put
all the actors together and said it's
like you know you guys are an extended
family and then just they had to kind of
improvise everything because that's a
very very natural uh interactions
between them so it's very very easy to
believe that these are two actual like
family units and the way they're
interacting with one another
so as i said casey she's probably like
16 i guess something around there 15 16
years old and she's kind of you know
rebellious uh kind of teen so she
apparently was elaine's daughter before
because i think it's uh mentioned at
some point just kind of like a throwaway
line that elaine was pregnant when she
was a teenager so she had casey when she
was very young and then subsequently
she's married this other guy jonah and
they have had two children together
so there's kind of that whole dynamic
now they arrive at this very remote
uh you know it's very beautiful and very
snowy
at this very remote uh kind of really
nice
country house type situation
uh which is owned by elaine's sister
chloe chloe's husband robbie and they
also have two little kids nikki and leah
now
nikki
is um kind of he's probably seven eight
i don't know it's really hard for me to
tell how old kids are
and leah is probably like i said five or
six i think i said earlier that miranda
was younger than she was miranda
actually looks like she's more like
eight or nine she looks like a little
bit older like i said i kind of got the
names confused because there's a lot of
there's a gaggle there's a gaggle of
children in this movie and um so it so
after a time they just become kind of
this you know force or whatever
so they've showed up they've got
christmas presents they're all like they
haven't seen each other in a long time
it's this big you know fun thing now the
first thing that's a little bit off that
happens
is that uh one of the little kids paulie
who's as i said probably like four or
five something like that
uh he gets out of the car and before
they even go in the house he starts kind
of throwing up
now
they
obviously you know it's a kid they get
sick all the time so no one's really all
that concerned about oh he must just be
carsick or he's got a bug or something
like that no biggie you know he's fine
they all go in the house and proceed to
kind of kind of just kind of hang out
catch up you know have a few drinks and
just kind of have kind of a good time
you know what i mean it's the holiday
season and uh it's family members they
haven't seen each other in a while and
all this other stuff
now uh as the night goes on though it
does seem that whatever this mysterious
illness that polly had is starting to
kind of spread to the other kids and
what ends up happening is that it seems
like
it almost seems like the virus is
affecting the youngest one first and
then it's kind of jumping to the next
oldest and the next oldest and the next
well at least that's what it seemed to
me i don't know it's not really uh you
know it's not really explained to any
extent but at this point so the kids
just signed it they just kind of feel
like you know they're just kind of seem
like oh yeah they're just kind of sick
they look a little bit pale um you know
and they look a little frowny and it's
like they kind of irritable and cranky
and stuff like that so as i said as you
would as most normal people would oh you
know whatever
paulie had it must have just been some
little flu or something like that and
now some of the other kids have it too
and uh so it's no big deal so they just
kind of send them all to bed now the
interesting there's like an interesting
kind of interaction going between
the sisters like elaine and chloe chloe
is the older sister
and she's kind of like and like i said
they don't the nice thing about this is
that there's a lot of stuff
that happens in this that's just
revealed sort of organically and in the
sense of you know it's a real
conversation that people would have that
gives you insight into the character
without there being like exposition or
anything
you know so just from a line or two you
get the idea that chloe
is kind of one of those
i'm going to homeschool my kids annie
vaxx kind of people like just one of
those like natural crunchy granola type
women
so she's one of those
and her husband is kind of more like
he's just kind of going along with it
he's kind of a more fun loving type of
dude
and uh so they have that whole thing
going on and then elaine and jonah
elaine is kind of seems
you know she's the younger sister she
was obviously kind of rebellious as well
because she was pregnant when she was
you know a teenager and uh chloe had i
guess had a role in like raising her
because it's implied that their mother
was kind of a fuck-up and that maybe
elaine is sort of following in her
footsteps a little bit like kind of
being a party girl type of situation
although she is responsible you know now
she has three kids like a teenager and
two younger ones and so it does seem
like she's kind of come into her own now
she's obviously an adult but she still
has a little bit of that kind of like
party girl sort of uh thing
jonah is kind of like
he's kind of it's funny because of his
like casey like later on in the movie
like calls him a knob which he is kind
of because honestly
they're just going up there to hang out
with family and hang out with the kids
and open presents and have dinner and
drink and have a good time and he's
basically up there trying to sell
his brother-in-law
on this new business venture that he's
trying to
uh that he's trying to bring to fruition
like about chinese traditional medicine
he's you know having his he's teaching
his daughter to speak mandarin and he
can't really like chill out and just
relax he's always kind of like so
there's some implication too
that maybe he really needs some money uh
and he needs some investors in this new
business idea that he has and uh but
robbie is just like not really having it
it's like look it's the holidays you
know why you like coming to my house and
he doesn't say this but the implication
being that jonah's trying they're being
very earnest and he's brought all this
he brought like all his paperwork with
him and he's like i really have to talk
to you about this chinese traditional
medicine it's like you know when they're
trying to have like a fun party dinner
or whatever he's always trying to like
bring it up so you can tell there's like
a little bit of desperation there as
well there's also um
and again not explicitly uh you know set
up
but there's also this real tension
between jonah the step dad and casey and
particularly because uh they're jonah's
other like real natural biological
daughter miranda is kind of like daddy's
little princess whereas casey is just
kind of like oh my wife's teenage
daughter and it doesn't help but casey
is kind of like you know rebel she looks
like she's got like the avril lavigne
kind of [ __ ] going on uh so she's got
like little purple streaks in her hair
and so she's kind of gothy looking and
she's kind of like a smart ass she's
kind of sarcastic um you know in the way
that she i don't want to say she takes
after her mom because her mom's not
really like that but
you can see that she's kind of like the
odd person out because
you know it's like we have two couples
here and they both have two little
little kids and then she's like a
teenager so she can't really hang out
with the little bitty kids and she can't
really hang out with the adults either
because she's not really old enough to
drink or she's not really old enough to
like participate in that so she's kind
of like
you know she's kind of stuck in the
middle and she's not having a good time
and honestly what she's done because she
really really did not want to come on
this trip
is that
she had actually secretly called a
friend of hers because i guess the trip
coincided with some big party that she
was really dying to go to with her
friends
and so she's really pissed at her mom
for making her come to this thing
instead of going and hanging out with
her friends so she actually secretly
like calls her friend on the cell phone
it's just like hey this is where i am
come pick me up and then we'll you know
and you can drive me back to the party
so she's got this whole plan set up
where she's gonna leave now as all of
this stuff is being set up i don't
really want to call like the beginning
of it i don't know i watched some other
reviews of it and some people thought
like the the first part was like a slow
burn i didn't really think it was all
that slow because
you know that something bad is gonna
happen you know this is a killer kid
movie um and i think they do a really
good job setting up
all the character interactions and all
of their
you know giving them some character
development without being too
heavy-handed with it like i said just
you get a lot of idea of their
backstories and things like that without
much dialogue just kind of the way they
act with each other and just like little
things little throwaway lines they they
say so i think that's a really good i
mean it's just a really good setup um
and like i said their interactions with
each other are very very natural and
even though it's a horror movie and
obviously people are gonna make maybe
make some decisions that uh are not the
brightest nothing in this
struck me as like why the [ __ ] would you
do that you stupid idiot it was it was
all like believable like coming from the
characters
so as time goes on yeah like i said the
kids all start getting sick
miranda who is a little bit older
starts being like i don't want to hang
out with these little little kids
anymore because they're acting weird and
the way that they act weird like
sometimes they'll like paulie keeps like
banging on this xylophone just like all
the time and he won't stop doing it and
like staring off into space but it's
just they're all acting like a little
bit strange
and
the parents honestly they just kind of
feel like oh well maybe they just have
the flu and that maybe they're just a
little bit ill and we're not really
going to worry that much about it
because they're having such a good time
you know because it's the holidays and
everything so they just kind of like
write it off and they write off miranda
saying i don't want to hang out with the
kids because they're acting weird and
casey also noticing that the kids are
acting kind of strangely but as i said
no one really thinks that much about it
as you wouldn't if this happened in real
life now the first thing that happens
that's kind of important of the carnage
to come is that the kids are playing
outside you know it's kind of like they
got little sleds and snowballs and
whatnot because it's winter time
and uh chloe comes out with a big tray
full of hot tea for everybody because
they're all sitting outside watching the
kids
and uh one of the kids very deliberately
pushes the sled down the hill so that it
whacks chloe in the back of the legs and
like she spills tea all over everybody
now obviously you know nobody thinks
much of this it's oh it was just an
accident it's not that big a deal um
although jonah gets really really bad
about it because this t spilled all over
all the paperwork that he brought about
his business idea and he basically goes
and spanks paulie who was the kid that
was he's thought responsible for it and
then starts yelling at casey like why
weren't you watching them and she's like
bro it's what the [ __ ] i didn't do
anything like i'm just i'm just standing
here you know so it was just an accident
like calm down
so you know that kind of passes by
uh but there's other things that that
are kind of like hinting at what's to
come because they have a cat named jinxy
and obviously something bad is going to
happen to the cat which you know as soon
as you see it basically there's a shot
like inside this little tent they have
this little tent outside that they play
in in the yard and uh it kind of goes in
there where the kids are sitting because
miranda's kind of hiding from the other
kids because she thinks they're acting
weird and there's uh jinxy's collar is
in there so you obviously know something
bad happened to the cat although they
don't tell you what it is until later on
um so basically then
they have this thing where they're
trying to have this big i assume it's
boxing day like i said i think because
they all have the paper crowns on and
they're having like a big meal and
everything and so they're all kind of
trying to have a good time and then all
the kids start acting just like
horrible little hellions they're all
just like whining and none of them will
eat and they're like banging on stuff
and and uh you know so the parents are
trying to like deal with it and still
trying to have a good time
but it's just like not happening
so
uh eventually though what ends up
happening is that chloe tries to go and
get one of the kids to you know eat her
peas or whatever because she's acted up
and uh the kid basically just like
whacks her in the head and like cuts her
head open and then starts screaming and
freaking out so it's just kind of this
whole situation dinner is ruined all the
kids are now just screaming and grabbing
knives and doing all this crazy [ __ ] so
they're just like okay well we need to
like separate these kids so uh jonah
takes his little princess miranda
upstairs who is just screaming her
little head off and uh robbie takes the
other kids outside to play
now
this is the stage where everything gets
like really
bad because then
uh like i said you had the foreshadowing
of like the sled hitting chloe in the
back of the legs and like her spilling
tea all over everything but now you have
something a little more calculated and a
little more deadly i guess because
what happens is they get robbie and
they're like hey let's go play and they
put him on the sled like face verse and
they push him down the hill and then
nikki one of the other kids like pulls
his little wagon in the path and has put
like this big [ __ ] rake or some [ __ ]
in there so it ends up that robbie's
head like hits this rake and like tears
his [ __ ] head open
so robbie actually ends up dying like
from because his head wound and
everything so they call uh you know the
emergency services but because it's
snowing and it's everything like that so
they tell them well we can't really get
there like it's going to be a long time
so obviously everybody starts freaking
out now nobody really
that's kind of the great thing about and
i guess about killer kid movies in
general
is that you know what would you do if
your precious child and through no fault
of their own really because the
implication in this it's not super like
over explained or anything like that it
looks like it's basically just a virus
or a bacteria of some kind that's making
them turn against their parents or
making them turn against adults in
general because there's a couple shots
of you know the kids are puking and then
there'll be like um shots of kind of
like microorganisms
briefly like inside the thing so it's
obviously some kind of virus that's
affecting their brains and like making
them murderous and like i said that's
pretty much the only explanation
that you're given it but the adults
obviously don't know that and they don't
it takes them a really long time
to want to believe it because the first
few terrible things that happen could be
written down as like oh accidents just
kids being kids or they didn't really
know what they were doing or they didn't
know the gravity of it or anything like
that so
nobody other than casey
who's kind of seeing all this [ __ ] go
down
she's the first one to sort of twig onto
the fact that hey these kids are
they're they're not right and there's
something wrong with them and
there and we're all in danger but
obviously the adults don't believe her
because like i said these are precious
little children they're only like five
or six years old and why would they do
such a thing even if they were saying oh
they're just sick it's you know it's
fine they're just uh you know that's why
they're acting that way but they don't
want to believe that the kids are
actually like
[ __ ] with them and are actually like
out to kill them uh but spoiler alert
they absolutely are so after robbie gets
killed paulie then goes to his dad and
basically like slices his arm with the
knife and everything but still they
still don't want to believe it like i
said it's just they're little kids
they're sick um you know they don't know
what they're doing
but uh at this point paulie had done
some [ __ ] too where he was like up on
the monkey bars like that out in the
yard and uh he looked like he was gonna
fall like oh my god i'm gonna fall off
and everything like that and like his
mom starts to climb up there but then he
keeps like you know going just out of
her reach and everything so she has to
keep like reaching across and reaching
across and the uh the monkey bars are
slippery because it's snowy and you know
they're icy and stuff and she ends up in
a really nasty scene except honestly
that i honestly had a hard time watching
i've seen this movie like three times i
think at this point it's really good i
mean if you haven't seen it uh but
there's this horrifying scene where
she's reaching across trying to get the
kid on the top of the monkey bars and
she slips and her
shin goes like in between like the
ladder thing and she falls backwards and
like her shin just goes ah it's just
like the bone just pops out oh it's so
nasty and it's just the sound effect
that makes it i was just like like every
time it like [ __ ] gets me but yeah so
she breaks her leg and casey finds her
and has to like take her in the
greenhouse and then paulie basically
comes in there like trying to [ __ ]
murder them and all this other kind of
[ __ ] and then uh they discover too that
the kids have dragged robbie's dead body
like into the tent and are like playing
with it and it's just all this [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] happens like i said i don't
know if i necessarily want to spoil
everything that happens but
i mean this came out in 2008 but i feel
like a lot of people really haven't seen
it and it's kind of a shame because
like i said it's a really good really
effective
horror movie and i feel like it really
flew under the radar like i said even in
its home country of the uk it barely i
mean it got a theatrical release but
it made hardly any money and it seemed
like it didn't do all that well and it's
kind of sad because this is like a
really really good movie the child
actors are
amazing um i like that they just kind of
act like real kids they're not
they don't come across as though they're
acting
at the beginning of the movie before
they start getting sick they're all just
acting like real kids would act it's
very naturalistic
and the adults are as well like the
interactions between them
but the kids are just very naturalistic
and then once they start getting sick
i think the director made the really
good choice if it would you know if it
was that
that the kids are not overplaying it you
know what i mean they're not being like
like evil anything like that most of it
it's just like really subtle and it's
really creepy like they're just kind of
they they don't look good they look kind
of like they have the flu like they're
kind of pale and their eyes are kind of
sunken and you know sometimes they'll
just be playing and then they'll just
kind of like look off into space or
something like that so i think it was
better to play it that way it makes it
much creepier and you know the the build
up was like a lot eerier because the
kids weren't over playing it or like
overdoing it um you know they don't once
they turn evil they don't really talk a
lot but it's creepy because when they do
talk they
you can tell that they're like i said
very calculating in the sense that
they're trying to lure their their
parents or the adults into a situation
where they can kill them um so you know
when they have to they'll be like oh
where's mommy oh i don't feel good and
stuff like that but it's like they don't
you know once they kill the once they
start killing the adults they don't talk
about it they just kind of like sit
there and like look you know what i mean
so much much creepier than like a kid
trying to
going way over the top because then it
kind of shades over into like being
funny uh this movie not funny
not really and uh honestly like i said
i feel like a lot of american movies
about killer kids
would largely shy away from showing uh
for example a five-year-old boy being
impaled by a broken glass but this one
uh this one goes there so uh you know
pretty pretty much everybody dies in
this [ __ ] movie including almost all
of the children so uh yeah in horrible
ways uh you know so you know
eight-year-old girl getting hit by a car
and smashing into the [ __ ] windshield
it's like you know what i mean so so if
you don't like to see violence against
children in movies even if the children
are evil um you know then maybe this is
not the baby for you because it actually
does show a lot of these kids
getting their comeuppance but like i
said it's
it's it's kind of a complicated thing
because as i said the kids it's not
their fault they got they got a virus
but that said you still want the adults
and but you can also understand like why
the adults are really reluctant to i
mean you know this is your five-year-old
kid like staying in front of you like
all cute and everything and it's like
you
could you actually like kill them if you
had to if you thought the kids were
gonna kill you and uh so it does kind of
like bring up this
maybe uncomfortable uh sort of situation
particularly if you're a parent i mean
it's not obviously it's not the same
uh you know it's it's not the same
heaviness for me because i don't have
any kids but if you did uh and you watch
this you know you can imagine yourself
in that situation just being like man
could i
could i run my kid over with a car if i
thought that she was gonna get can i
stab my you know five-year-old my chair
with my little cherub of a five-year-old
kid could i stab them in the face if i
had to you know what i mean so this kind
of like brings a lot of that up so it's
very violent uh particularly toward the
end
but you know like i said a lot of kids
get killed and then at the end
uh it kind of implies that well
everybody's kind of [ __ ] because
it sort of opens it up to uh you know
this wasn't the only location where this
happened you know what i mean so it's
almost kind of like i want to say it's
like a zombie outbreak because they're
not zombies they seem like they still
have their [ __ ] together they just got
sick and the sickness turned them
murderous and calculating uh and also
i don't want to know i don't this i
don't i don't know if i'm just like if
this is just me like seeing this but it
also kind of
seemed like it made them a little bit of
a hive mind type situation too because
they all seem to
just they don't talk to one another
about what their plan is gonna be
but they seem to know like how to
orchestrate like particular things so i
think maybe it does kind of maybe like
connected them somehow like this virus
or whatever so uh so yeah so as i said
this is a really really good winter
christmasy new yearsy
uh horror movie that i feel like and
more people really need to see it
because it's really really well done
especially if you like killer kid movies
easily one of the best killer kid movies
i've ever seen just because it takes it
very seriously and all the characters
are believable and and like i said
they'll do
the movie does some [ __ ] up [ __ ] to
kids like it's not afraid to go there
which you know it's very ballsy which uh
i actually really
liked about it i thought it was you know
very brave of
it to go a cat does get [ __ ] up but
you don't see much of it uh that
bothered me more than the kids getting
[ __ ] up i don't know what that says
about me but uh but yeah so if you're
looking for something to watch around
christmas time
and you haven't seen this one i would
definitely recommend it uh it's actually
really easy to get hold of it's on 2b
for free if you have amazon prime you
can watch it on there for free
i think it's also on vudu for free so
you can see this like pretty much
everywhere without even having to pay
for it which you know quite a bargain uh
for as good a movie as it is i mean just
like because it has like such a generic
title i totally never would have watched
this
unless i had
if i hadn't like seen someone else like
on a list recommending it
and then i found it on 2b and i was like
man why you know and i think i've
mentioned this before like i think a lot
of people have a misperception of 2b
it's just like yeah it has a lot of
horror movies but a lot of them are
shitty not so uh there are actually a
lot of shitty ones on there i'm not
gonna say that but there are actually a
really lot of hidden gems in there it's
just really diffic because there's so
many you really have to like wade
through and you know look for
recommendations and stuff like that to
find the ones that are worth watching
and this one definitely definitely is so
as i said if you're looking for a
christmas horror movie that you haven't
seen before
then check this one out and let me know
what you thought about it in the
comments i really liked it a lot as i
said i've seen it three times at this
point and it's just it's just a great
it's beautifully shot beautifully acted
just uh just a really tense [ __ ] up
violent
horror movie uh you know gotta love the
killer kids so uh that'll do it for this
flickers of fear and i will see you guys
on the next one
bye